in Syria Kurdish forces are accusing
turkey of failing to abide by the terms
of the u.s. brokered ceasefire and its
leaders are calling on vice president
Mike Pence to take responsibility for
its enforcement it comes as Russian
leaders reportedly huddled in Syria
today to discuss the escalating tensions
in the region Holly Williams is near the
Syrian border in Turkey good morning the
United Nations said the border between
eastern Syria and Turkey was mostly calm
yesterday but there are reports of
violations of the ceasefire by both
sides 14 civilians were killed by
Turkish led airstrikes and mortar fire
according to a Syrian monitoring group
200,000 civilians have reportedly fled
the area in recent days and Turkish
backed militants have been accused of
atrocities against Syrian civilians the
u.s. effectively opened the door to this
Turkish incursion into Syria last week
when President Trump announced that US
troops would be pulling back from the
border region US forces numbering around
a thousand and now in the process of
withdrawing entirely from eastern Syria
that decision is a betrayal of the
Syrian Kurds according to many both in
Syria and in the u.s. including
Republican members of Congress a
kurdish-dominated militia group has been
America's closest partner on the ground
in Syria in the fight against Isis and
now they are the targets of turkey's
assault turkey abused the Kurdish group
that partnered with the u.s. as a
terrorist organization President Trump
called the ceasefire agreement a
stabilization the u.s. withdrawal could
ultimately benefit the Syrian regime and
its allies Russia if the ceasefire
breaks down there are also fears for
accused Isis fighters being held by the
Kurds we were given exclusive access to
one of their prisons last month they say
they're holding around 12,000 former
Isis fighters including 4,500 foreigners
the nightmare scenario is that with
renewed fighting the Kurdish group will
no longer have the resources to properly
secure the prisons and there could be a
mass escape of Isis fighters Dana Holly
thank you very much